bonjour liez merci d'être avec nous
merci on est très heureux de t'avoir
avec nous lles juste on voudrait
rétablir une vérité parce qu'il ya plein
de gens sur les réseaux sociaux qu'on
dit qu'on fait pourquoi personne
intervient et tout ça et tu peux nous
confirmer que mine de rien les reporters
et un reporter qui était avec vous êtes
intervenu tout à fait un reportage qui a
est intervenue après faut savoir que ça
a duré à peine dix secondes donc elle me
voilà le temps de réaction derrière nous
il y avait un groupe de jeunes qui
commençaient à s'avancer vers nous donc
voilà c'est toujours délicat seller je
voudrais juste dire que les reporters et
les journalistes qui ont fait ce truc ou
et est reprochable ne croyez pas qu'ils
étaient là avec leur caméra a filmé à se
dire oui on s'en fout on film quoiqu'il
arrive et on n'intervient pas donc je
voudrais rétablir cette vérité parce que
y'a plein de gens sur les réseaux
sociaux que l'on dit c'est inadmissible
personne n'a rien talent les images de
ce reportage
sous son incroyable un solide yes
alors il ya un moment où tu va
distribuer des tracts dans ton quartier
et regarder comment il est accueilli
yes ça ça fait froid dans le dos ce
garçon à vélo va vite passer aux menaces
les
méliès ne se laisse pas impressionner et
alors oui et alors et alors c'est quoi
le problème
on a eu des témoignages de personnes
homosexuelles qui nous ont dit qu'ils
étaient là bas qui devait se cacher
d'autres qui ne se cachent pas qu'ils se
font souvent agressés donc on peut pas
les laisser tomber comme ça alors il
venait de proposer des tracts pourquoi
pour eux pour ceux qui n'ont pas vu le
reportage
en fait c'était une distribution de
prospectus dans la ville où je
souhaitais c'est chez ragen vinet
c'était une distribution avec stop
homophobie l'association dont je suis
membre est allé on a choisi ce quartier
c'était le quartier du luth
voilà c'est ça d'accord alors vous
pensez qu'ils ont bien fait diffuser les
images valérie bénaïm parce que
malheureusement moi j'ai regardé dans ce
reportage à bord qui était debout
tambour remarquable parce que il faut
montrer aussi que l'homophobie ce ne
sont pas simplement des petits mots
par-ci par-là de ci de là une insulte un
peu plus violente éventuellement sur
twitter ou autre c'est aussi le mot
phobie c'est aussi des coûts c'est aussi
de la violence physique
et voilà et la force de ceux de ces
moments-là de 7,2 cette image là c'est
que nous mêmes on est on a on a eu un
recul devant la tirer en se disant mais
c'est pas possible c'est passé pas voilà
et le boulot de journaliste et de
montrer ce qui n'est pas possible
justement alors il ya un autre extrait
on a pu découvrir hugo un jeune
homosexuel de 17 ans il a choisi de
changer d'école pour fuir l'homophobie
on n'a rien jusqu'à peu hugo était
scolarisé près de chez lui dans un
établissement privé catholique
il était harcelée par quatre élèves
alors il à changer de lycée en cours
d'année
il se rend désormais au centre de paris
à une heure de transport dans l'anonymat
de la capitale hugo se sont plus à
l'aise qu'en banlieue en région
parisienne il faut constater dans les
dents les codes
si on n'a pas les mêmes activités que
l'on veut pas au foot on va pas jouer à
la ps4 quand on rentre chez nous par des
troupes comme ça on est forcément aux
pays qui sont là d'accord alors liesse
où on a vu ça aussi toi tu penses que
ces images qui était contente qu'elle
soit diffusée
clean de rien moi je suis pour justement
la diffusion d'un bien est ce que c'est
ce qui se passe c'est la réalité
c'est ce passé c'est mon quotidien c'est
le quotidien deux ans vit une surface
d'angers pour les jours donc on va pas
cacher ou modifier la vérité voilà on
montre la vérité de ce qui se passe est
grave voilà c'est courageux de votre
part mais depuis la diffusion le ça se
passe mieux où ça se passe encore
bah si vous voulez l'opinion publique
elle est là donc les au niveau des
hommes politiques des pouvoirs publics
c'est ça qui va faire bouger les choses
c'est pas en ne montrant rien en se
cachant que ont fait bouger les choses
c'est en montrant à cette violence comme
telle quelle est la réalité des choses
quoi alors moi j'aimerais savoir ce
qu'ils sont contre la diffusion de ces
images ce que je suis je suis assez
étonné gilles verdez pourquoi alors je
suis contre farouchement contre d'abord
bravo à liesse pour son courage mais
contre parce que la direction de france
télévisions expliquent qu'ils ont
réfléchi pour eux ça a un sens très bien
sûr mais pour moi ça n'a pas de sens
c'est un lynchage homophobe mais est on
au mot pour moi mais oui mais bon peut
faire sa faveur pour moi de ma langue
mon chauriens ont fait semblant de rien
mais laissez-moi m'exprimer pour moi
montrer la violence d'un lynchage
homophobes
ça risque d'être contre-productif
d'inciter et pour moi ça peut être un
risque énorme donc voilà pourquoi je
suis creed hôtes allemands contre lille
il aurait dû réfléchir plus long et le
passé n'est jamais d'accord ninni des
âneries franchement gilles je suis
désolé tu dis des âneries c'est débile
ce que tu dis son activité excuse moi tu
fais et moi je me permets pas si je le
dis là c'est débile franchement cette
utilité publique de diffuser ces images
pourquoi parce que les jeunes qui nous
regardent et les jeunes qui regardent la
télé il pense que les agressions
homophobes si anecdotique et ça ne l'est
pas et ça ne l'est plus et ça ne l'est
de moins en moins c'est violent c'est
comme ça c'est terrible de voir ces
images
moi ça m'a fait pleurer ça vous a fait
réagir ça doit faire débattre et
franchement bravo bravo à gilles si je
préfère une gilles comment tu peux
imaginer tunisair être contre-productive
et il n'y a pas des gens qui vous
regardent et 110 ans
tiens c'est vrai que ça a l'air sympa on
va les faire une razzia la nature et au
contraire ça fait chaud qui arrive est
dangereux pour moi je ne veux pas de
danger il ya déjà suffisamment violent
de l'homophobie dans les banlieues alors
à ce moment-là le quotidien liesse comme
on en parle alors comme on en parle à la
télévision on n'en parle pas oui mais je
ne m'a dit 'ça syrie s'il suffisait
d'enlever cette séquence des violences
pur b le reportage en lui-même il était
incroyable il était puissant il n'y
avait pas besoin que cette scène selon
mappy fr je voulais en fait je voulais
juste a ajouté que moi c'était des coups
bonjour je je m'en sors assez bien avec
le soutien de beaucoup de monde
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux
mais je tiens à préciser que il ya aussi
les mots les injures les sketches les
sketchs même les plus anodins qui
peuvent conduire au suicide et moi dents
au sein de mon association stop
homophobie et bien je prends un exemple
après les propos du pape on a un jeune
ben c'était la goutte d'eau qui a fait
déborder le vase et d'un qui s'est
suicidé voilà avec des cachets qui s'est
suicidé c'est alors je voudrais
remercier déjà le protocole national
c'est un peu faux billets aussi
alexandre marcel et bravo pour tout ce
qu'ils font aussi parce qu'on est chez
qui nous regarde on lembras on embrasse
fort